actually don't sit down i want to start
with something before we get going here
i just need like a boxing tip like i i
don't intend to get into a lot of fights
i don't get in a lot of fights in my
everyday life
but just in case i know you've been in
the ring with floyd mayweather yeah
arguably the greatest boxer of all time
so yeah
put my hand so i gotta say first you
should be asking my brother this
question okay okay he's undefeated and i
am the opposite okay but you did go
eight rounds with floyd i believe yeah
okay okay okay okay okay okay so i gotta
take my watch off for this one so no you
don't have to take the watch off what
are we doing here put your hand like
this which one uh this one all right so
i'm a little bit of a unorthodox fighter
and i i fight with my hands
and my jab is is not your typical jab
from up here i do like a snappy jab kind
of like a backhand
jeez jeez
like it's it's like a background my
health care plan
no no it's all good no you got to try
though all right so it's like imagine
like a backhand as a jab okay
a little more i'm a little more little
more yeah yeah yeah a little oh back to
that you know what let's do the panel
okay all right all right good enough
good enough
okay stick to writing columns is what
you're saying right no it's good it's
good i saw the tenacity in your eyes all
right listen if i ever win a fight you
get 10 how's that sound thank you i
appreciate that so i want to get to the
boxing stuff but this is the wall street
journal logan so we probably should
start with some business cool
you've been at this
i don't know how old you feel but you've
been at this for a long time now i was
looking at the record it's it's almost
10 years for you and the business of
social media yeah you're only 27 yeah
but do you kind of feel like you know
you've been around for a while in the
business yeah i do i realized uh
when young creators would start coming
up to me that i'm now the vet okay and i
had that moment with the creators that
inspired me okay and i kind of look
around at the landscape and
i do have a pretty keen understanding of
social and that only comes with time so
i do have to admit uh
yeah i'm i'm
i'm knowledged into space because of my
experience like i i am a vet social
media feels like it should be measured
in dog years i mean it feels like 10
years should be 80 years or something
like that i mean because it's always
changing yeah there's always a new
platform and each platform has a
different language just like uh
you know code on a website um html5 uh
das whatever it is it's a language and
social is the same
i just happen to get good at speaking
the different languages
native to each platform
now if you could go back and visit
logan paul circa 2012 2013 we're talking
about still at ohio university guys
still starting out with vine and you
could give yourself a couple of a piece
of advice for the next decade what would
you what would you say to that guy
i would have told him to go for it it's
it's the it's the one thing i didn't
think i did until i had a case study
that proved to be working um when i
dropped out of college i finished my
first year um with a 4-0 it was a hard
decision because i i am a bit of an
uh academic
if you will um
what were you headed toward like you had
none of this happened what do you what
career do you think i was going to be an
industrial and systems engineer okay i
don't even know what that is they focus
on efficiency in factories fantastic
yeah
so um it was creative though you know i
i my goal at that point in time was um
to invent a product that would
revolutionize the world
and uh it turns out media allows me to
exercise that creative part of my brain
um and it's a lot more fun
yeah yeah i bet i mean there was no
blueprint for this there was no book you
could check out amazon there was no how
to be a social media star you know it
meant successes it meant mistakes you've
had some high profile mistakes too what
did you learn along the way what do you
think were the most critical lessons
yeah you know you mentioned blueprint um
i i think i think anyone paving the way
um kind of making their own blueprint
understands the difficulties of what
goes into it because
you know there's no there's no path to
follow you're paving the path but it
also leads to sometimes the most
rewarding results yeah um i've had a a
a career full of ups and downs successes
and failures but i i i take everything
everything that i do and and i and i
apply to the next thing that i do the
learnings and the understandings and
just like i i've gotten i've gotten good
at
acknowledging
and accepting my truth and my reality
and then using it to move forward and at
this point you know
i've done a lot um
i joke with my friends like i just i
know too much
i know too i know too much and like i i
feel like i can i can i can use what
i've learned to continue you know
creating that blueprint
the flip side of all this the flip side
of internet fame or any kind of fame
really is that there's gonna be a
certain number of people are gonna love
you there's always going to be a certain
amount of people who dislike you maybe
even hate you and that's the way it
works and
anger is a very potent thing on the
internet sure
does hate roll off of you at this point
or does it stick to you and bother you
sometimes
no no hate rolls off of me i uh i have
empathy for anyone who has legitimate
hatred in their heart
feels um burdening to me i i simply
don't have um
i don't know time to to
to focus negative energy anywhere and
and and i've barreled through it all and
i've learned that like truly truly if
you if you don't give up you're gonna be
a tough person to stop and and and and
social media is full of
you know
haters naysayers doubters
and to me it's you know it's all just
noise because it really is it's a big
world and everyone has an opinion but if
you know who you are and you know what
you're up to and how you're going to get
there none of the other stuff matters i
mean a word that gets brought up all the
time to the point that it's almost
meaningless is authenticity and you once
said like this brand i've built you
either love me or hate me for exactly
who i am there's no smoke no mirrors
you know can you judge when you're
looking at other people who are coming
up when someone's being genuinely
authentic versus like sort of fake
authentic sure sure of course now and
not only just me i think i think um
the internet and people in general are
becoming more and more aware of who is
real you know it's and i i truly do
think authenticity will be
the key for creators celebrities
influencers in this next decade because
you know
everything we see has a level of
superficiality to it or like fickleness
or
you don't know if it's real or fake even
just like
um
more macro like deep fakes now like in
the next 10 years or so you're not gonna
know who's saying what because you're
able to recreate someone's face and have
them speak as if they're them you know
they're probably on the flip side of
that there are probably people who argue
like well what are giving me the need
for like paying influencers so we can
just create them do you think there will
always be a fundamental need for actual
humans to do this i think i think i
don't know i don't like to speak in
absolutes right but um so i wouldn't say
always but my knee jerk reaction would
be yes i think i think i think like
genuine authentic human connection like
ability uh the ability to navigate and
garner attention
comes with
a human a homo sapien sabian so yeah
um
you have a famous younger brother he is
famous uh i don't know if you know that
um you mentioned him at the top i
believe you live across the street from
each other yeah yep are you competitive
with each other or is this a real
partnership no not anymore uh there was
a time this is embarrassing to say but
um
my most viewed youtube video is a diss
track against my brother
so yeah there was a time where we
we were definitely enemies um and then
we realized you know
this is a weird journey
personally i have one brother whom i
love dearly and he's always going to
have my back no matter what and in this
interesting eccentric difficult to
navigate life that we happen to end up
in there's not another person i can i
can turn to that truly understands
what's happening and why
you know we we grew up in ohio together
in the woods like locked out of the
house for 13 hours a day because our dad
made us you know play outside and do
manual labor
and then all of a sudden you know i'm
fighting floyd mayweather and jake is
one of the highest paid athletes in the
world
how does that happen
it's surreal i mean i don't know the
last time you guys got in a car together
just alone and drove somewhere but what
is that conversation like just the two
of you it's it's they're the best
conversations i have in my life because
we spend time apart from each other yeah
and and he has just as much uh uh
passion for life and and fervor as i as
i do yeah and so we we learn we collect
absorb knowledge um
learnings meet people and then we
exchange information and it's sort of
like a um
it's sort of like a mastermind yeah when
you know i'm just hanging out with my
brother and and
he'll fool you online but
i think eventually
it'll be kind of understood like jake's
jake's a genius like the kid's
incredibly smart and so i get to see
that side of him which is always
fascinating now i want to ask like an
old man question about civility
i'm going to sound old for a second but
you know it seems like the thing that
sticks the most nowadays on social media
is
confrontation
anger abrasiveness hate you know is
there room for love is there room for
being somebody famous on the internet if
you're about positivity and
and you know using your forces for good
i mean it's clear there's been a
maturation in your process that you're a
different guy than you were five ten
years ago for sure
yeah it's it's a really great question
so my answer
would and i'm a bit of an idealist would
be yes yeah i hope so too
unfortunately i think most of our
species uh
love loves the the the negativity the
drama it's just like that's kind of
where we lean
for for what reason i don't know and
i've
gotten the opportunity to position some
really positive messaging behind some of
my content because of preconceived
notions about who i was right
or who i am you know
which which is which is interesting but
yeah you're you're absolutely right
spreading love spreading positivity like
in general like no one wants to see that
[ __ ] you gotta like you gotta like navi
you it's and it's unfortunate and it's
true and that's why the people who are
good at it yeah are good at it and and
um are making the ways that they are
because when you can figure out how to
spread positive messaging and really get
people to feel and care which is which
is kind of the staple of what i do my my
my only um hope with with my content is
i just want to make people care and make
people feel there's been a lot of
conversation on all social media
platforms about the idea of content
moderation and like whether or not
things should be more verified or you
know shut down if they get too crazy
what's your take on you know whether or
not there should be you know somebody
under the hood making sure that things
remain a little bit more civil
online
i don't know i think it's i think it's
important i also think free speech is
important obviously um yeah what do you
think of musk you know bid for twitter
oh man i i think it's great just because
i believe in elon um and i and i and i
believe he'll do good things for the
platform but you know there's there's
the spread of disinformation is
incredibly dangerous
incredibly dangerous and it needs to be
moderated what that looks like i don't
know i'm not elon musk but i'm sure
he'll put um some some boundaries in
play
to protect like the sanctity of free
speech but at the same time not allow
you know radical dangerous ideas to
spread i'd hope if he called you up and
said
you know what would be your recommend
for something like twitter
why are you calling me eli
okay so you we talked about this a
little bit at the top but you're also
going to market with products of your
own prime hybration which is hydration
it's uh there you got it right there
okay this is with your old boxing buddy
ksi yeah yeah
now i think of uh sports drinks as a
pretty crowded marketplace uh but what's
going to make this one work what makes
it stand out
uh what sports drinks do you think of
when you think of the crowded market
well i think of what's the one from the
university of florida gatorade i think
of the body armor
vitamin water uh red bull is that a
hydrate no that's not hydration drink so
there's three yeah right and uh vitamin
water i wouldn't even say it's a sports
drink it's more hydration which is what
we are we're hydration and lifestyle got
it and
um if you can break in which we did the
market actually isn't that crowded we
actually just passed powerade and sales
at target we're the fastest growing
hydration drink in america and we're
focused on hydration and lifestyle uh
our drinks have less than 25 calories
two grams of sugar 10 coconut water uh
800 pour it over a coach when i went to
championship yeah and they won't get
sticky like trust me
your coach you got spilled gatorade on
is going to be sticky
not with prime so
this product started out of um a belief
that there was a hole in the market that
hadn't been filled yet yeah and and
i mean
based on the numbers it turns out we
were right and it has it has an
incredible story behind it you mentioned
it
um i i
fought my first boxing match ever was
with a fellow youtuber by the name of
ksi he's uh uk's biggest internet star
and arguably uk's biggest star um it was
a tie
we had a rematch showed out the staples
center in la and he beat me
i lost by one point
i'll never forgive jack reese for taking
away those two points but it's fine
because it allowed us to come together
then afterwards set aside our
differences and we had about two years
of realizing that me in case i we were a
lot more alike than we were different
and i don't think there's a better
uh arc than two people who literally
hated each other
beat the snot out of each other and then
came together to start a global beverage
brand that's that's cool to me and it
shows there's like it feels like there's
an inherent sense of like hope yeah in
in in building you know like you that's
what i'm saying i don't i don't have
room in my heart for hatred yeah like at
one point jj and i were convinced that
we hated each other we were able to set
it aside and build something really
meaningful and important and i think is
going to be like a mainstay in in
hydration and beverage
um
you must get pitch things all the time
what's the worst idea you've ever been
pissed oh my god
you know it's it's tough i'm not i'm not
super nice with pitches like like it's
tough because dude i hear them all the
time yo let me pitch you my nft i go
stop
i don't care i'm sorry please i don't
want to hear about your
your donkey nfts
leave me alone but you are getting into
this business i mean you are into this
thing that's recently launched called 99
originals which people on your team call
your magnum opus and this is you know
not just about you it's building what i
learned is this decentralized autonomous
organization or dao yeah um sort of this
online community um but these are wild
times for collectibles nfts right now
you've probably seen the market
i don't know if you look at your
portfolio but um it's it's wild out
there but i imagine you're more
optimistic than that i am optimistic so
i'm optimistic in my project originals
um
i launched it absolutely the worst time
any human could launch
an nft project um but i believed in the
project uh enough because again the
story behind it the significance and i
think the the depth and what it
represents in crypto blockchain art
technology uh dow's decentralized
autonomous organizations which you which
you meant uh or i mentioned
um
i i i just really believe in my product
as i do with all my products otherwise
why why am i touching it i'm not gonna
waste my time on something that i don't
believe in and so yeah um originals was
this polaroid nft project i traveled the
world for 99 days it took 4120 polaroids
uh traveled 85 000 miles and i selected
99 finals to mint and turn into nfts um
sell them one by one over a period of 99
days the buyer of the nft gets the
physical one of them you get the tactile
polaroid right exactly yeah yeah and
then and then what we're doing is
building this decentralized autonomous
organization so the holders of the
polaroid get to join this group that
have access to a community treasury that
they can collectively decide what to do
with i think dials are the future i
think
the groups of people without one
particular leader and and access to
funds that people have a collective
decision-making ability to do creative
things with
is the future it makes sense to me and
by this you mean it's not just going
into logan paul inc it's going into this
50 of it is going into a shared resource
among the people who are kind of become
shareholders of this essentially it's
almost like it's almost like a modern
day like very simple version of a fund
right you know like right now we have a
hundred and i think 107 eth in the
treasury treasury which
you know right now is like
almost a quarter million uh and and
we're 10 days in and in theory that
could be invested into other projects
and build from there whatever whatever
the community wants to do we'll vote on
it but yeah i mean fun independent
artists or or movies um sponsor events
donate to philanthropy like honestly
anything i want to get to some questions
but i just want a couple quick questions
about uh fighting sure i paid for the
mayweather fight
i was super ready to hate it feel ripped
off and i was like you know what this is
really entertaining this is really
you know this is kind of what i wanted
what i felt i paid for um you know i
feel like with boxing you managed to get
into the one business that was crazier
than the business you were already in
right it's like yeah but but it's clear
that you and jacob found this avenue
here
finding events that people are
interested in seeing did boxing feel
like a business that was ripe for
disruption absolutely yeah it's a cheat
code i i sort of got it to cheat code
when you were a kid you were on the
playground
and a fight breaks out where does the
attention go
everyone goes to the fight yeah it's the
same thing in real life again like we're
pretty easy to understand species and
it's the same thing in real life if you
have enough of a draw and you are
willing to get in that ring or that
octagon and quite literally risk your
life for entertainment
put the work behind it and you gotta
you got a formula for success there i
mean it's amazing to see the boxing
community were like what the heck are
these guys doing and now they're like
they want to come in they want to bring
their fighters together
yeah jake just um jake just
uh put on the the biggest female fight
in existence right uh amanda serrano
versus katie taylor sold out madison
square garden had these women paid more
than they ever had in their entire life
and and this is like you know at first
it was a young youtuber it was kind of
like a gimmick and now the kid's
undefeated he's one of the biggest
promoters in boxing right and um
you know it's
it's revitalizing a sport that like
deserves a lot of attention
let's get to some questions in the
audience here i'm sure there are some we
have
right in the front yes
howdy i have a two-part question so
first one is i mean you did pokemon
cards then the prime the 99 originals so
like obviously you're a great influencer
and creator but how do you come up with
these creative ideas for like
entrepreneurial stuff to really leverage
your personal brand that's that's a
great question
um the honest answer is i don't know i
have i have this
innate ability
to dive to the deepest parts of my brain
and if there's something in there that i
like
i'll take it bring it back and refine it
so i'm a creative at heart i think i was
blessed with like the the ability to let
my brain run
and i've gotten good at just refining
and
having a keen understanding of what
people are going to care about it mind
you dude i'm not always right in fact
i'm still wrong often but i'm also still
very young and every time i'm wrong
you know
that's a takeaway that's a that's a
blessing for me is there something just
a little bit different than say like if
you were just going on selling
merchandise hats and shirts and whatever
then selling investment properties which
effectively was what nft is so people
can go in there and they could make a
killing or maybe they could lose money
on it that's a different dynamic than
just selling plain merch how does that
change your thinking it's it's it's what
i mentioned at the beginning it's a
language and you have to speak it
according to the platform that you're
navigating on um
you know merch currently now for
influencers is kind of
overdone yeah and so
do we still want to put our energy into
that yeah i don't know yeah um i thought
i could make a significant nft project
with originals turns out thus far i'm
right um and i you know again i just i
believe in the product yeah and i'll run
into the ground if
if so let's go we got another question
that is in the back there could i finish
my second part question yes sir oh sorry
we just want to get one question from
each person if you don't mind i'm sorry
thank you i love you
nice to meet you man thanks for coming
out um my question is you're definitely
super influential and a leader in the
space for youtube and social media what
would you
recommend to someone who's trying to
break into this space which feels so
late in the game at this point yeah dude
great question because you're right it
is so hard
and it's so saturated i
had the blessing of
starting video when i was eight years
old before a youtuber was even a thing
so when
influencers became popular i had been
doing the thing that they had been doing
for years and i kind of found a way um
and i i
feel
uh
empathy for creators now who are trying
to break into the space i don't know if
you all know but
the majority of gen z took a survey and
like these kids just want to be
influencers
they want to be youtubers and i'm like
no please
like please
be careful um we need some doctors yeah
you got you have to you please we need
doctors be a doctor
uh you have to you have to have
something special about you is the
answer i think it has to be innate i
think like we mentioned earlier like an
authentic likability
and you're you're you're filling a hole
that that no one's really doing just yet
every new creator i see that makes it i
go that makes sense or or or
you know musician um actor it just
they fit
um and sometimes you gotta break your
way in you know it'll take a decade of
work before
you fit but you put in the work and like
i don't
see how you can't make it happen
appreciate it thank you this time just
blew right by and we have time for one
last question and i'm going to take it
logan uh because i'm going to ask my
stock question at the end of interviews
with logan paul which is you can look
right down the barrel of that camera
are you going to be running for
president
in eight years you put it out there the
possibility you'll be 35 uh in in about
seven years uh or eight years rather
that would put you at 2032. uh are you
going to run for president logan paul
i logan paul
will be running for president
in 2032.
we can book that yeah sure and
just
you know john f kennedy made bobby his
attorney general where is jake gonna go
uh in the cabinet jake is the secretary
of defense okay
logan paul everybody thank you very much
[Music]